aujourd'hui à tam tam retour sur la
fermeture d'alphabet est la plus grosse
plateforme de vente illicite de drogues
réchauffement climatique
est ce que la politique québécoise de
quotas pour les voitures électriques du
gouvernement pèsera sur les plus démunis
les espaces sauvages un lieu de création
en arts modernes au coeur d'alger mais
d'abord le premier ministre du canada
est à la une du magazine rolling stone
qu'en est il du vedettariat de nos
politiciens
[Musique]
bonjour ici raymond des marteaux
bienvenue attentats mais ici en studio
avec moi si vous nous suivez en facebook
live avec chantal jeune dame marie
claude simard bonjour et leonardo qui
mène à allô allô bonjour bonjour bonjour
à tous après bill clinton après barack
obama c'est au tour de justin trudeau de
se trouver en une du rolling stone
pourquoi est-ce qu'il peut pas être
notre président se demande un brin
provocateur à le magazine c'est écrit
d'ailleurs vous allez le voir à propos
du premier ministre canadien
le journaliste qui a fait le papier dans
leur liste se nomme steven roddick
rogers qui disent bien il a dit le va et
vient entre et citant trudeau justin de
va et vient entre la presse et
gouvernement est essentielle pour que
fonctionne une démocratie quand la
presse est à son meilleur
ça nous pousse à faire de nous mêmes à
nous à faire de même du bien ou
s'interrogent
ou serait-ce qu on s interroge de
stéphane rodrigues il dit est ce qu on
sait ce qu'on est dans les chroniques de
narnia
on est dans sous une tente de
récupération d'un festival pop parce qu
on est en 2009 non il dit nous sommes à
ottawa nous sommes aujourd'hui à peine à
900 km au nord de washington
voilà quelques années pour ceux qui s'en
souvient peut-être pierre elliott
trudeau le père du premier ministre
actuel avait déclenché quelque chose qui
s'est appelée la trudeaumanie
trudeaumanie au canada tant qu'entité
devenu chef du parti libéral par la
suite premier ministre puis ben voilà
que le fils maintenant à son tour se
retrouve à la une des pages qui sont
loin d'être politique c'est pas aucun
d'access manifeste en construire deux
jeunes avec son saxophone ses verres
fumés spectacle à une émission de télé
de grande écoute de fin de soirée
arnold schwarzenegger lui même aux états
unis qui avait annoncé sa candidature au
poste de gouverneur de la californie
encore une émission de fin de soirée en
france au début des années 90 il y avait
même une campagne qui avait vu le jour
pour inciter fortement yves montand à se
présenter
la présidence on pourrait continuer
comme ça longtemps
aujourd'hui 2017
alors des nouvelles en continu des
réseaux sociaux dit gazouis à outrance
savait qu'ils pointent qu'en est il du
lien entre la fonction publique de chefs
d'état et l'image sociale du vedettariat
à outrance qui est la traduction
française de peopolisation là c'est le
néologisme qui est rien alisha talent
chez vous qui avez fait le papier cette
semaine là dessus en fait c'est un c'est
un papier que j'ai fait avec beaucoup de
plaisir parce que franchement notre
premier ministre à la une de ce magazine
travaille pas loin l'un de l'autre et
attoub chambre l'entendez sourire oui
c'était tellement amusant de voir comme
ça justin trudeau à la une de ce
magazine là on sait que généralement
c'est quelque chose qui est réservé aux
super star rock star sportive mais là on
est dans un autre domaine on n'est pas
dans le monde de la musique si vous
voulez ou du sport on est en politique
c'est autrement plus sérieux on pose des
questions vraiment qui interpelle le
public c'est quoi l'intérêt de notre
public du public en général de voir le
plus ministre justin trudeau à la une
d'un magazine qui est d'habitude réservé
aux gens qui font de la musique voici
jalousie et de conserver longtemps
qu'ils font de temps en temps des photos
à la une autre personnalité ailleurs que
la musique tout à fait c'est pour cette
raison qu'on parle de la pipolisation de
la vie
mais oui je parle de ce néologisme c'est
très très important
c'est vrai que c'est un anglicisme
quelque part mais franchement il faut
dire que dans les années 2000 ce mot la
vue
avec cette surexposition des hommes
politiques dans les médias quelques
passes affole le scandale parce qu'on va
fouiller dans leur vie privée
tout autour on ramène leur ville alors
je vais dire leur vie secrète sur la
place publique ce qui quelque part peut
réserver quelques surprises désagréables
méritions besoin fouillé le dossier vous
si vous avez trouvé des trucs
intéressants
oui mais d'abord d'abord votre opinion
là dessus ben écoutez c'est évident que
monsieur trudeau a pris ça très au
sérieux cette entrevue là parce qu'il
eut accordé vraiment beaucoup de temps à
ce journalisme sur rodrigues
alors on voit que pour lui aussi c'est
très important qu'avec les deux de
paraître dans la revue rolling stones
d'ailleurs murdoch a fait un très bon
papier pour que s'adresse au public
évidemment aux lecteurs uniques et donc
à les amasser beaucoup de choses qu'on
sait déjà au canada mais ayant fait
quelque chose de très comme on appelle
human un feature sur le dos de l'enfant
c'est intéressant je lui pose aussi des
questions intéressantes sur ses
décisions politiques comme par exemple
pourquoi tel décidé de d'augmenter le
budget militaire au cours des dix
prochaines années
quelque part ça ça contraste un peu avec
son image pacifistes et puis un peu si
on veut alors il lui a quand même posé
des questions aussi ça que des questions
sur
son appui d'une certaine façon aux
pétrolières quand même temps il était au
sommet de paris d'accord alors appelé
cépages années quand même pour poser des
question intéressante quoique de prime
abord ces papiers intéressant en fait
oui juste dire de petits mots c'est
certain pas bien intéressant mais je
trouve qu'il y a un problème d'équilibré
et qui vibre de l'information parce que
dans le fond ils présentent justin
trudeau sous son plus beau jour
quelqu'un de conciliante qui change tout
en ordre
excusez moi franchement c'est vraiment
un personnage lisse avec tout est beau
tout passe bien sauf que quelque part il
ya des choses qu'il faut pas refaire
aussi oui mais je pense que c'est en
fait utilisé trudeau pour critiquer son
propre président alors c'était c'était
en fait un traité ces contrées pour
vraiment ombrage à 32go exagéré le
personnel avait des trudeau pour
vraiment diminué son propre président je
pense que j avais pas cru en lui lui
elle est d'accord il ya compris
un trou d'eau ça fait longtemps
l'importance de l'image l'importance des
médias de médias sociaux et a compris
comment ça marche maintenant
et toi tu dises et des autres présidents
qui ont qui ont fait aussi la une pile
mais lui ils savent quoi faire avec ça
avec ça il se sert des médias
je pense que c'est très intelligent de
sa part utilisé dans l'instant pour
faire ça en fait c'est laisser aller
avec un instant et puis c'est vraiment
un travail
c'est lui la personne la salle par
sanquer et il y apprit tram comme il
fallait dans les moment des faits c'est
comme l'huile à l'aller nemesis c'est
lui le mi6 d'être envoyée oui ils
participent
on peut pas être ailleurs de la guerre
on peut pas mettre de l'argent dans la
guerre entre guillemets mais je pense
qu'il sait sert très bien il se sert
très bien des médias sociaux depuis il
est il fait quelque chose de bien dans
les années 60 car à quel point
l'accélération est inouï il ya eu un
débat télévisé
les premiers débats télévisés entre les
candidats à l'époque c'était à kennedy
et nixon qui avait perdu et nixon avait
refusé d'être maquillée kennedy avait
bien acceptée à la télévision c'est à du
noir et blanc à l'époque et il avait
passé comme on dit qu'il va être là
comme une brute s'est défoncé la chose
et il est devenu président au fil des
années la les verts l'un la presse dite
d'image la presse dite de deux grands
portraits le paris match par exemple
pour où le veau 28 ça ça change la
perception des gens par rapport à qui
sont ces hommes politiques voilà et qui
deviennent des vedettes au delà de la
plateforme et de ce qu'ils disent le
sens de ce qu'ils défendent en
communication politique je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui se défend très
bien parce qu'au fond qu'est ce qu'on
enseigne à ces gens là on leur dit il
faut passer ce qu'on appelle le tube
cathodique
c'est à dire quoi il faut se servir de
ces médias là pour lisser son image pour
poly sons images apparaître comme
quelqu'un d'agréable surnombre dans le
cadre d'une élection parce qu'on veut
aller chercher un électorat on veut
toucher des personnes et quelles sont
les personnes qui se laisse toucher de
cette façon là généralement c'est les
jeunes qui sont sensibles à l'image
c'est les femmes
oui on voit un président ou un premier
ministre beau il est tout beau sa femme
est belle ces enfants sont beaux ils
sont photogénique audit le dit dans son
article
vous voyez donc quelque part c'est un
test réussi pour justin trudeau qui
passe bien ce tube cathodique là je pèse
bien mes mots derrière arrivé à
construire l'image qui a maintenant qui
sait il en profite
il n'ya profite tellement et c'est ça
son côté et fort oui je pense que son
côté faure politique c'est vraiment
l'image qu'ils vivent est ce que vous
voyez ça ailleurs sa planète est ce que
vous avez constaté ce genre de choses
n'ont habituellement regard trop d'eau
comme ça dans la planète
moi je vis de l'argent il y en a vu d
une vidéo faite en espagnol en montrant
trop d'eau comme les politiciens qu'on
voudrait avoir qu'on voudrait avoir
et j'ai les boules et s'il n'y a pas
peur de dire qui a fumé de la marijuana
y laisser les politiciens qui a pas peur
de se promener et dans les parages ne
les parades gay celle qui à part des
l'image tu as fait selon moderne qui se
promène avec sa femme ses enfants qui
n'a pas peur de s'exposer qui dit tout
haut ce que les autres pensent tout bas
et n'osent pas le dire jusqu'où va
m'arrêter un prédécesseur de cette
approche là oui mais oui bien sûr puis
je pense qu'ils aussi la la la la
relation avant de finir
et mme obama en fait la relation avec
trou d'eau il ya commencé à faire que
mons pc passage la jetée j'étais donnent
le bâton les vins coaticook qui continue
mais moi je vais pas m'arrêter au niveau
d'obama souvenez-vous de marie
antoinette
ben oui jusqu'aujourd'hui dans les
médias ont par la voix de marie
antoinette à un phénomène qui date
d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas toujours
continuer à parler d'elle alors c'est ce
qui s'est vraiment savoir en profiter de
l'image
euh en fait
eva obama marian thani était bail
je pense qu'ils pensaient pas ça met de
la prose jeu parce qu'il utilise l'image
peace est très bien dans les moments qui
ont envie c'est vraiment l'image c'est
encore mieux pour trudeau pour son image
que ce soit rom qui soit la présidence
qu obama day sales o'grady parce qu'il
correspond tellement un mythe de la
vedette doit vous montrer une caricature
oui ce matin en me rendant au bureau
dans le métro j'ai pris le journal du
métro le 24 heures et puis la caricature
de monsieur mathieu rodrigues qui publie
sa caricature tous les vendredis dans ce
journal
donc on va la montrer à l'écran parce
que je pense que l'image terrible savez
ça s'en vient qui va piano va sano
c'est vraiment l'image on la décline
parce que simplement trump qui aura très
en colère que tu es là le papier du
rolling stones avec la une avec justin
trudeau qui dit alors
en face il ya un peu raison parce que
c'est pas vraiment une trêve d'être là
mais c'est une vedette
c'est une vedette aujourd'hui délabré
c'est un vétéran de la politique n'a
très intéressante et aujourd'hui
justement notre le premier ministre
actuel par rapport à l'ancien premier
ministre loterie monsieur rené plus
nulle part dans les politiques non mais
on dirait que le phénomène trudeau a
tout emporté sur son passage a tout
balayé parce qu'on ne parle plus comme
son père de ces années 60 68 69 telle
bête elle fils alors vous êtes un peu
fort hydra correspondait pas vraiment
aux critères de bagdad
non plus au niveau du look en tout cas
au québec c'était une image de son image
était plus difficile aussi 7 se veut
d'état ria vous n'êtes que la planète
planète média en argentine par les
ailleurs sur la planète on observe ce
qui se passe ici par rapport à la
communication l'utilisation de l'image
par le premier ministre perd son bureau
approché aussi ça risque de faire tâche
d'huile selon vous les eaux ailleurs sur
la planète mais oui bien sûr ça fait il
laisse une trace pour le reste il faut
apprendre avec à vivre avec les médias
sociaux d'aujourd'hui c'est comme ça que
les gens s'informent maintenant c'est
comme ça qu'on voit là en fait on
continue à voir en partie de la vérité
le manioc c'est ça exact mais je pense
que lui il fait vraiment ils l'utilisent
très bien puisque
il s'en sert pour pour des profits et
pour l'éthique savate intéressant à
suivre la suite des choses vous allez
chantal jean d'esme marie claude simard
leonardo crime est notre l'e3 merci
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est un
plaisir très agréable si vous êtes sur
facebook là ils vont vous dire voir m et
si vous nous suivez ailleurs sur autres
plateformes je vous dis que la suite des
choses il sera question d'alphabet la
fermeture la plus grande plate-forme dé
vente illicite des drogues
il sera aussi question de voitures
électriques au québec lui est ce que la
politique québécoise de cauter pour ces
voitures là est-ce que ça pèsera sur les
plus démunis et on parlera aussi des
espaces sauvages c'est un lieu de
création en arts modernes en plein coeur
d'alger ici raymond des marteaux au
revoir ou a tout de suite
[Musique]